en el último vídeo tuvimos esta ecuación
diferencial y al menos parecía que
podría ser exacta pero cuando tomamos la
derivada parcial de esta primera
expresión respecto de i era distinta a
la derivada parcial de esta segunda
expresión respecto de x lo cual nos dice
que no cabe en el mundo de las
ecuaciones exactas muy bien eran
distintos y dijimos o caray bueno si no
es exacta qué pasaría si pudiéramos
encontrar una función que nos haga al
multiplicar esta ecuación por esa
función que nos haga que sea exacta
dijimos bueno si multiplicamos ambos
lados de esta ecuación con una función
new de x y que vimos que era x entonces
nos hacía una ecuación diferencial
exacta ahora ésta me podría depender de
y podría depender de las dos variables
xy no importa lo que importa es que hizo
el truco de hacer esta ecuación una
ecuación diferencial exacta muy bien a
este tipo de funciones las conocemos
como factor integrante de todos modos
ahora vamos a resolver el problema
multiplicamos de ambos
por la función de x que es x y bueno del
lado izquierdo
ustedes notarán que obtenemos la función
3x cuadrada porque más x porque cuadrada
que es simplemente multiplicar por
nuestra función new y ahora del lado
derecho tenemos x al cubo más x cuadrada
porque y que esto multiplica a ye prima
y del lado derecho tenemos cero que es
cero por new de x
ahora vamos a comprobar que en efecto es
una ecuación diferencial exacta que pasa
al dividir esta primera expresión
respecto de ella que ya vamos a llamar
que es nuestra función m y tendremos que
la derivada es 3x cuadrada más 2x y esto
fue el resultado de derivar esta función
m respecto de y ahora analicemos qué
pasa al derivar respecto de x la segunda
tenemos 3 x 4
+ 2x y que simplemente ahí lo tenemos
estas 2 derivadas que calculamos fueron
iguales lo cual nos dice que esta
ecuación es exacta muy bien además la
solución de esta nueva ecuación es la
misma que de la anterior verdad no no
está cambiando en nada la propiedad de
la ecuación diferencial exacta perdón la
ecuación diferencial original entonces
ahora como como procedemos sabemos que
nuestra función si tiene relación con
nuestras funciones
mn sabemos que la derivada parcial de
pepsi respecto de x es igual a nuestra
primera función que es la m que es 3x
cuadrada porque más x porque cuadrada
correcto entonces encontramos una
primitiva de ambos lados y tenemos que
si es igual a la integral de esta
función respecto de x que es x kubica
más que es la integral así un medio de x
cuadrada por ye cuadrada y por supuesto
aquí hay que hay que agregar algunos
detallitos verdad porque faltaría
agregar una una constante que en este
caso pues una constante en para fines de
integral respecto de x puede ser
cualquier función que dependa de ella
así que vamos a tomar ahora la
información que tenemos del lado derecho
de nuestra función n lo que sabemos es
que nuestra app si su derivada parcial
respecto de y es la función n que es
igual x cúbica más x cuadrada y así que
qué pasaría si ahora derivamos esta
expresión respecto de y bueno esto
simplemente nos queda si al derivar lo
respecto de ella tenemos x cúbica más la
derivada de cuadrada es dos por un medio
se cancelan los dos y nos queda x
cuadrada por qué
la derivada de h respecto de ella que es
la parcial de h respecto de ella pues
simplemente es derivar la verdad y a
continuación tiene que ser igual a
nuestra función n que simplemente vamos
a sustituir esta expresión acá abajo
entonces esto debe ser igual a x al cubo
más x cuadrada porque ahora si notamos
pues esto es interesante porque ambos
términos están de ambos lados entonces
simplemente está x cúbica se va a esta x
cuadrado porque se va con esta otra y
nos queda finalmente que la derivada de
h respecto de ye es igual a 0 o
simplemente al integrar tenemos que
nuestra función hdi es igual a cualquier
constante
muy bien ya obtuvimos quien es h
realmente no es una función de ye ya
vimos que esta función pues es cualquier
número constante verdad por lo que para
nuestros propósitos podremos decir que
en realidad es es cero realmente o sea
nos vamos a quedar simplemente con esta
expresión porque al ser estado una
constante de todos modos ya vimos en
vídeos anteriores que esas constantes se
guardan en una sola verdad vamos a vamos
a detallar esto más adelante para por si
no se acuerdan pero bueno aquí la
ecuación diferencial se puede reescribir
como la derivada total respecto de x de
exit utilizando la regla de la cadena
como ya vimos esto es igual a cero
entonces si tomamos una integral de esta
expresión
de esta expresión de la derivada pues
tendremos otra equivalencia de esta
ecuación verdad tendremos entonces que
si debe ser igual a cualquier constante
por eso realmente no nos importaba qué
función perdón que constante nos
tomáramos para nuestra h de verdad
entonces nuestra solución queda
implícita como x cúbica y más un medio
de x cuadrada porque cuadrada y esto
bueno aquí como les comentaba hd ll si
pusiéramos cualquier constante
y esto debería ser igual a una constante
si tuviéramos la otra constante pues
solo pasa del otro lado restando y sigue
siendo constante verdad de todas formas
ahí tenemos tuvimos una ecuación
diferencial que superficialmente al
menos no parecía desde una ecuación
diferencial exacta pero luego cuando
multiplicamos ya vimos que si la
podíamos hacer exacta a través de una
mide x que es un factor integrante y que
obtuvimos en el vídeo anterior muy bien
al multiplicar por x ambos lados
obtuvimos ahora esta nueva ecuación
diferencial que si era exacta y
encontramos una sí que depende de xy de
ye tal que su derivada fuera 0 o bien
reescribir la como que esta función si
fuera igual a una constante muy bien
entonces para encontrar esas y como ya
hemos hecho sabemos que la derivada de
pge y respecto de x es m integramos
respecto de xy obtenemos si salvo por
una función hd y como encontramos esa
función hd y bueno pues simplemente
esta expresión la derivamos respecto de
iu y la igualamos a nuestra función n
correcto entonces eso nos da una
ecuación diferencial para h que pues
simplemente era era muy sencilla esta
ecuación y al resolverla obtuvimos que
hd es una constante pero bueno dijimos
que esta constante era cero por todos
los argumentos que ya hemos dado y la
solución está dada por si igual a una
constante que es x cúbica yemas un medio
de x cuadrada y cuadrada igual hace
entonces insisto podríamos tener la
constante de la h de iu pero bueno creo
que ya lo hemos hecho muchas veces que
ya deberías entender qué pasa con esa
constante verdad simplemente vamos a
ignorarla
de todos modos eso es todo por ahora y
espero los vea en el próximo vídeo ahora
que ya sabes de factores integrantes